DAVID GREGORY: Back now at 8:36
with Education Nation Today.
This morning, how
technology is leading
to a new kind of learning.
NBC's Craig Melvin
is here with a look
at the classroom of the future.
Hey, Craig, good morning.
CRAIG MELVIN: David,
good morning to you.
Savannah, good morning
to you, as well.
From text books to
tablets, have you
ever wondered what
our classrooms
will look like 10, 20,
even 50 years from now?
Well, some innovative
thinkers are
unlocking new and powerful
ways to teach our kids,
changing the way we look
at our education system
in the process.
The numbers alone
are staggering.
JOSE FERREIRA: The thing
about the education system
is, it's a very
impersonal system.
It's a factory model.
CRAIG MELVIN: One student
drops out of high school
every 26 seconds.
Roughly 30% of kids
each year will not
graduate from high school.
That's 1.3 million
in all, falling
through the cracks of
our education system.
Worldwide, the numbers
grow exponentially.
A whopping 80% of kids will
not get a high school diploma.
Experts say each of those
kids is a lost opportunity.
How many DaVincis and Einsteins
and Marie Curies and Michael
Jordans are we losing
every generation
because we're just
not giving them
the opportunities
that some of us have.
CRAIG MELVIN: But what
if that could be changed?
What if an internet
connection was the difference
in getting a world
class education.
Today, education is having
that internet moment.
And a chosen few are taking
some bold steps forward.
JOSE FERREIRA: I'm Jose
Ferreira, the founder
and CEO of Newton.
We're trying to revolutionize
education across the globe.
CRAIG MELVIN: Newton is an
adaptive learning platform
that personalizes education
based on each kid's strengths
and weaknesses.
In essence, students
go at their own pace
and the software continuously
adapts to their learning style.
JOSE FERREIRA: If you learn
math best with medium difficulty
practice questions,
we know that.
If you learn science best
in 24-minute bite sizes,
we know that.
Everybody has a
learning experience
that is unique to them.
CRAIG MELVIN: Ferreira
started the company in 2008,
using his credit card.
Since then, Newton has
grown by leaps and bounds.
They currently reach almost
five million students,
and that number is growing.
JOSE FERREIRA: We
want to end the access
problem for education.
We want every kid, whether
you're in the inner city
or in the developing
world, we want
you to have the best possible
education you can get.
SAL KHAN: My name
is Sal Khan and I'm
the founder of the Khan Academy.
CRAIG MELVIN: In 2004, Sal
Kahn was tutoring his cousins
remotely from his
then home in Boston.
The lessons started
over the phone,
until a friend
suggested he upload
educational videos to YouTube.
SAL KHAN: And I
immediately said, no.
Videos and YouTube, that's
for cats playing piano,
not serious mathematics.
But I gave it a shot.
And those videos took
on a life of their own.
CRAIG MELVIN: Those videos
became the cornerstone
of Khan Academy,
a virtual library
of now more than 4,000
tutorials covering everything
from basic math to
college level chemistry.
SAL KHAN: And our goal over
the next 5, 10, 50, 500 years
is to go from the six
million students that we're
serving every month now to 60
million, 600 million students.
CRAIG MELVIN: One of those
students recently sent Khan
a video message from the
unlikeliest of places,
an orphanage in Mongolia.
STUDENT: Hey, Sal.
Your lessons are so
interesting and funny.
Make more lessons.
SAL KHAN: That by
itself is pretty mind
blowing for us, this idea that
the work that we get to do
can reach people as far as
an orphanage in Mongolia.
CRAIG MELVIN: Two companies
led by two visionaries, both
using the reach of
technology to reimagine
the future of education.
And now Newton
recently partnered
with education publisher
Houghton Mifflin Harcourt.
As a result, more
kids will have access
to their adaptive
learning platform.
And we should note, Khan
Academy's mission statement,
changing education
for the better
by providing a free, world
class education for anyone,
anywhere, that means all
of their tutorial videos
are free of charge.
SAVANNAH GUTHRIE:
That is pretty cool.
DAVID GREGORY: Great stuff.
Great model.
CRAIG MELVIN: Thank you.
Good to see you.
I'm looking forward to seeing
you dance in a few minutes,
too.
DAVID GREGORY: Well,
you never know.